what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
mcu and chiang chi is dominating at the
box office right now it had a
record-breaking opening labor day
weekend and that is quite impressive
considering the fact that there are
still many theaters closed throughout
the world but shangchi is absolutely
crushing it and i have no doubt that
spider-man no way home is going to crush
it as well and today i think i might
have found a connection between chiang
chi and spider-man no way home i think i
may have figured out an explanation of
why we never saw doctor strange in
chiang chi the very first time i saw a
particular scene in chiang chi i
immediately thought this could be used
for spider-man no way home and after
thinking about it and formulating my
theory a little bit more i genuinely
think that we could have gotten a little
bit of a glimpse into something from
spider-man no way home in a very quick
scene in chiang chi and i don't know how
many people picked up on this because it
actually requires you to know a plot
league that has been proven real for
spider-man no way home so in this video
i am going to be talking a little bit
about that plot leak and i am going to
be talking about a little tiny scene in
shanxi one that is kind of a spoiler but
if you've seen the trailers you've
pretty much seen this scene so it's not
really a spoiler if you've seen the
trailers and it's a scene that lasts
like seven seconds long so it doesn't
really give anything about the movie
away needless to say you have been
warned and of course if you love marvel
and want to stay up to date on
everything be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so in chiang chi
katy and shangchi go to macau they go to
macau because of the postcard that shang
chi got from his sister or so at least
he thought when we get there we get to
the underground fight club and just like
we saw in the trailers when we get to
the main arena we see wang fighting
abomination and wang actually calls him
a meal during this fighting scene and
that's actually pretty important and
i'll get to that in just a bit now i'm
not gonna talk more about this scene
than i have to just so i can kind of
avoid spoilers but like i said they're
not really big but basically like in the
trailers we see a fight between wang and
abomination then after this fight shanxi
is up he's about to fight himself and he
goes kind of in the locker room area
where the fighters go beforehand and he
sees wang and he also sees wang leave
long uses his sling ring opens up a
portal goes in it and is gone however
when he opens up that portal with the
sling ring we kind of see what the
background is and here is where i
actually think we're getting a big
connection to spider-man no way home the
second i saw what was in the background
i immediately thought that could be what
they're using in spider-man no way home
and that is why we don't see doctor
strange in chiang chi now to understand
what i'm talking about you'll have to
know a little bit about this spider-man
no way home plot league so let me just
go over a little bit of it for those of
you who may not have heard it if you
have heard it bear with me for just a
second it's very short but it says
peter's life is ruined after his
identity was revealed at the end of the
last movie he is now facing trial matt
murdock is his lawyer peter goes to
doctor strange and asks him to cast a
spell to make everyone forget that he is
spider-man something goes wrong with the
spell and they break reality and bring
five spider villains of other dimensions
to the mcu green goblin doc ock the
sandman the lizard and electro and
here's the part that you need to pay
attention to it says that norman osborne
is talking to the others asking what is
the last thing they remember and they
all say the last thing they remember is
spider-man killed them with the
exception of sandman doctor strange
wants to take them back to their
original dimensions but the villains
fear that returning would mean that they
would return exactly where they came
from meaning they would die again and
here's the most important part norman
manipulates peter into freeing them
making him feel guilty for their deaths
peter fights doctor strange and breaks
the key which is a cube that held them
captive and the villains are now free
and that's all you really need to know
of that plot leak they break free cause
havoc peter has to fight them the other
spiderman join that's the movie but
circling back to shanghi it looks like
there is some sort of a magical cage in
the background of where wong is going
and this very possibly could be the cage
that doctor strange would hold these
villains in now the cube which is the
key to the cage we actually see in the
spider-man no way home trailer it's
actually in the thumbnail of the trailer
that sony has up on their youtube
channel it's in the part where doctor
strange sort of pushes peter's soul into
an astral projection peter is holding
the cube in his hand in this scene this
is what is said to be the key now again
circling back to when wang left during
shangqi we see this sort of cage in the
background and as you can see this is
not a normal cage it looks to be a
pretty heavy duty one and if wang or
doctor strange is involved with it it is
definitely enchanted by magic in fact
that cube could be the magical element
to it that's why peter could be running
around with it to try and get them back
now right away i want to address that
yes this could be for abomination but if
you notice the demeanor and the
relationship between abomination and
wong in shang chi it doesn't really look
like abomination is that much out of
control again not really trying to say
too much but it does look like
abomination isn't really much of a
threat and why would wang be holding
abomination in a cage why would he be
holding him and then taking him out for
certain events that part doesn't really
make that much sense and like i was
saying before this could actually
explain why we never see doctor strange
but we see wang in chiang chi if you
think about the wong scenes it really
does make you wonder well where exactly
is doctor strange if the events of
chiang chi are so significant then where
the heck is strange well we don't really
know when the events of shang qi take
place but we do know that they take
place after the events of avengers end
game because people reference the snap
we also know that it's a decent amount
of time after the events of avengers end
game because civilization seems to be
somewhat normal however since they do
reference people disappearing it's still
somewhat fresh this means that shangqi
could take place maybe right around the
time that the events of spider-man far
from home and no way home are taking
place this could be why we don't see
doctor strange he's too busy dealing
with the events of no way home he's
helping peter parker fight all of these
other villains and he's also you know
trying to keep reality together if these
movies do coincide with each other this
could be the cage that the villains were
held in but then got broken out of by
our peter good job buddy and even if
chongqi doesn't take place at the exact
same time as spider-man no way home we
do know what spider-man no way home is
setting up doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness so if it's not
during the same time as no way home it
probably is during the same time of
multiverse of madness in which we know
for sure doctor strange is going to have
his hands full and as far as we know in
chiang chi and the legend of the ten
rings he could be in a completely
different universe or another realm
chung chi after all does mention realms
as well but strange's absence and all of
the wong scenes is very noticeable and i
think the most logical explanations for
this is that he is dealing with the
events of spider-man no way home helping
peter parker out or he is helping
himself and in return the universe and
probably multiverse in multiverse of
madness because like he told tony stark
in avengers infinity war his job is
protecting his reality or the reality of
everything and everyone but let me know
what you think about this theory i
definitely think strange is not in
chongqi because he is dealing with no
way home or multiverse of madness but do
you think this cage that we see very
briefly in the scene could be the cage
that strange is using to hold the
villains of spiderman away home the
villains from another universe do you
think he could be holding them in this
cage protected by magic or that cube
that we saw or do you just think no
that's for abomination that's really all
there is to it i would hope it's more
than that and i would hope that they
have a cool connection like that to
spider-man no way home but let me know
all of your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you